in pursuit of tournament Redemption
Fabiano caruana survived a completely
lost game and turned it into a huge win
further proving that he is a machine in
complex positions on day three of the
chess kid cup Fabi faced alireza faruja
in the losers bracket a must-win
situation for both players alireza was
hunting for fabi's king and the result
was starting to look apparent that was
when Ali Reza played the disastrous
Queen C2 check allowing Fabi to move his
King to a safe square and gain a
significant Advantage with checkmating
ideas in an epic turnaround Fabby
claimed the first game game two evolved
quickly with the eval bar remaining dead
even suddenly on move 24 Fabi discovered
the brilliant Bishop takes F2 check
removing a Defender from Ali Reza's King
on move 35 Fabby maneuvered his Queen
into alirez's position alireza
overlooked the defense of his light
squared Bishop with Bishop E3 a
tournament-ending blunder